Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning, church. So glad you're here.
I know you had choices today. You could have been anywhere. It's Labor Day,
but I'm glad you chose to be in the house of the Lord to worship.
Wanna invite you to open your copy of God's word this morning,
we're gonna be in Psalm 62. Psalm 62,
a beautiful Psalm. My name is Perry, I'm your missions pastor.
I'm the new guy on the block.
And what an honor it is for me to come and just share with you from this
passage. It's a, it's a passage that's going to speak to all of us.
And the reason it will speak to all of us is because we will all pass through
these kind of things in our life.
Either you are coming out of a storm in your life and things
are looking better,
or you're in the middle of a storm and you're right in the thick of it right
now, or you're about to get into a storm and you don't even see it coming.
And this is a Psalms that will speak to us.
This is a Psalms that will bring amazing comfort to us during these times.
So you take this psalms,
you put it in your pocket because you're gonna need it someday.
We all will need it someday. You know, just in way of introduction,
this Psalms is the Psalms that David wrote during Absaloms with
son's rebellion when he was trying to kill David. And it's the Psalms.
This is that it's one of the most difficult times in David's life when he was
inspired by God to, to, to write this Psalms. It's when,
uh, Absalon has rebelled against him.
It's when it's when many of his trusted leaders have now turned against
him. And he's old.
He's old and feeling frail and there is imminent death
at the door. You have to ask yourself, what,
what is he gonna do? What will David do in those circumstances?
Lemme say something right here.
To be brought to a place where God is our only hope
is a merciful experience.
That doesn't sound right, but it's true.
To be brought to a place where God is our only real hope is a
merciful experience. But I don't say that lightly.
I don't say that lightly out of experience.
I know that these times always come in desperate
experiences. They always come in darkness.
The some extreme circumstance has happened in our life or some internal
conflict or internal crisis is we're in the middle of it.
And all of those things that you and I normally would use to get through that
period, they've just fallen short. They're not, they're not enough.
And we're left wanting and, and needing and, and they fail us.
It's in these moments that oftentimes we feel our weakness,
we feel our vulnerability, we feel fragile.
We feel like we're not going to be able to make it through those times.
And we'll usually during these times long and plead with God
for just an escape. Just get me out of these circumstances.
That's what this psalm is about.
That's what this psalm is gonna talk to us about this morning.
The first thing I want you to see this morning is a lesson learned waiting
for God alone. Psalm 62, 1 through four.
Let me read that passage and you follow along there in your copy of God's Word
For God alone, my soul waits in silence.
From him comes my salvation.
He alone is my rock in my salvation, my fortress,
I shall not be greatly shaken. How long,
how long will all of you attack a man and batter him like a leaning
wall or a tottering fence?
They only plan to thrust him down from his high position.
They take pleasure in falsehood. They bless with their mouth,
but inwardly they curse. Listen,
this is a psalm for those who are under stress.
This is a psalm during those difficult days,
and the key is found in verse one where it says,
for God alone, my soul waits in silence. Literally,
if you were to translate this,
the way that is said is only to towards God,
my soul is silenced. I love that.
Only when I'm looking at God is my soul silenced.
Now, let's just be honest.
When we're going through difficult times and trouble and life seems to be
imploding on us, I don't know about you, but my soul starts screaming.
I start telling myself, boy, if this doesn't happen or, or,
or this doesn't happen, or it happens and everything is lost,
if I don't get this or that, then and,
and then everything is going to come apart. In fact,
I go into kind of a mode of all or nothing thinking.
I don't even see the options anymore. It's just everything is gonna be okay,
or everything is the worst day of my life. It's just extremes.
During these times,
we assume during those times
that God is not enough,
not enough to get us through these times.
It's in the back of our minds.
Somehow we tell ourselves that we need a different circumstances,
we need a different condition.
We need some possession necessary to make us happy and to secure.
We worry.
We worry and we worry that God is not enough
to protect us and provide for us.
David, David had many desperate experiences in his lifetime.
I think about his life.
He lived in a brutal age and and endured tremendous pressure.
He lived in a time where, uh, most of his adult life, he had the,
he had death looming over him like a shadow almost every day.
He, he lived as a fugitive most of his life,
fleeing from King Saul's paranoia.
He's also a man that led many armies into battle and,
and faced war after war, after war, facing,
attacking armies. And if that wasn't enough,
David, for most of his life, experienced the anguish,
the anguish of knowing that some of his dear friends
and even his loving his love, his most loved son,
Absalom, had turned against him and was,
and was conniving and,
and wanted his demise and wanted his failure and even wanted his
death. And as I read the Psalms, I asked myself,
what did David do in those circumstances? I know what I would do.
I know what many of us would do. But what did David do? David,
he had learned to speak to his own soul.
And he had told himself, I need only one thing to survive.
I need only one thing to thrive, and I have it.
I only need God.
I only need God. And His all powerful fatherly love and his care,
everything else he says is expendable.
If I only have God, I have enough.
Listen, if you and I could learn that,
if you and I could grasp that and recognize that in our own lives,
we too would never be shaken. Like the Psalmist says here,
are you able to sing these words to God?
Are you able to pray a prayer like that? Lord,
I praise you for all of your sufficiency because you are enough.
You are enough in my heart. You are enough in my life.
You are enough in my joy, Lord,
I find rest in you alone.
Have you ever reached a place in your life
where you're silent and resting in the provisions and the
protection of God? If you haven't,
if you've never been there,
if you're always striving and manipulating and trying to claw your way of your
circumstances and you've never learned to stand before God in silence
and rest in him,
then you need to get to the end of yourself and you need to get
to the place where you can do nothing and God
can do everything in your life. In this Psalms,
we also see a lesson to be remembered,
and that is that salvation and hope are from God alone.
Listen to verses five through eight, for God alone,
my soul waits in silence.
For my hope is from him.
He only is my rock and my salvation, my fortress,
I shall not be shaken on God rests my
salvation and my glory, my mighty rock,
my refuges God trust in him at all times.
O peoples pour out your hearts before him.
God is a refuge to us. Sayah,
that little word sayah there means pause and think about
it. Pause and think about it.
And that's exactly what David did here in verse five.
He pauses and he thinks about the lessons that he learned in verse
one. You know,
there is a battle that goes on inside of us at all times.
It is the battle to shape our hearts with the knowledge of the
truths that we know in our head, that God has told us to be true.
And it's a constant struggle sometimes, and we, we,
we are sometimes our feelings and the promises we know to be true just
don't seem to align.
When I read the Psalms and I think about David in these circumstances,
David didn't seem like he was feeling like his faith was growing,
that he was getting stronger. In fact, when I read the Psalms,
I see that David under the pressure of all of this,
he's feeling weak and vulnerable and fragile. It says,
he says, in fact,
he feels like an old stone wall that's bowing
and about to crumble under its own weight. He says he's,
he feels like a rickety old fence,
just moved to Edmund, Oklahoma, bought a house,
and one of the first things I'm gonna have to fix and a rickety old fence,
I go by there with my weed eater afraid that the weed eater is gonna knock this
fence over, right? We've all seen those fences. Listen,
that's the way David felt. He said, I feel like a rick of your old fence.
It's just about to fall over if somebody were to lean on it or, or,
or even touch it. Fragile, vulnerable.
Sometimes in these moments
of learning to trust God,
it is difficult times the test that comes to us and cut the test
that comes to our faith often feels like a threat to our
faith.
We feel like everything's gonna be dismantled and whatever form of adversity
we're experiencing, it just feels overwhelming.
We can identify with David, we feel weak, vulnerable, fragile, like a,
like a teetering, uh, fence or a, a wall that could crumble under its weight.
Sometimes we even have the temptation to wanna panic and just run.
We, we, we run from our friends, we've run from God,
we run from all of our helps into the darkness in panic.
So what are we to do? What are we supposed to do in those times?
And here is one of the great truths of the Bible. The gospel.
The gospel. Look what the psalmist says.
Salvation comes from God alone,
not from ourselves and not from anything else that we can produce.
Salvation comes from God alone. Listen to Romans chapter four,
verse five,
and to the one that you and I who does not work
but believes in him,
Jesus who justifies the ungodly,
his faith is counted as righteousness. Listen,
there are many verses in scripture that teach this, that it's not by our,
our our our striving and our working and our pleading,
that we receive our hope,
our hope and our salvation are found in God alone.
We must learn to silence the voices of our fears and to speak the
truth of God's promises into our life.
We need to knowing that because of his great love and his grace for us,
we are safe and secure in the Lord counted as righteous because
of what Christ has done for us on the cross.
It is all sufficient. Amen.
David, uh, he not only counsels himself,
he counsels others. I think that's one of the measures of knowing.
When you actually are growing and, and getting better in your circumstances,
it's not just about you anymore,
but somehow with the comfort with which you've been comforted,
now you're able to help someone else. That's exactly what David does here.
He says, you people, he's talking to himself,
but he's talking to us and he says, listen, with the same comfort,
God comforted me. You can be comforted. Let me,
are you able to lay down the impulse this morning of,
of just doing things to secure God's blessings and able
to rest, to rest in Christ and what he's done for you?
That is the message of the gospel. Can you pray this morning, Lord,
teach me to cast my deadly doing down at your feet and
to stand in what you have accomplished in Jesus Christ,
gloriously complete in Christ. That is our hope,
that is our salvation. We learned in this passage too,
that we need to have a healthy skepticism.
We just can't be gullible here. It says trust in God and nothing else.
This passage starts and it says, Lowes of low estate are, but a breath.
Those of high estate are a delusion in the balance.
They go up and together,
they are lighter than a breath here.
David is telling us,
and he's basically taking all of those things that we normally look to for hope
and he's dismantling them. The first one he says is,
you don't need to trust in peoples, and he's used as plural or in the elite,
in the highs, in the specialist. I don't know about you,
but I can spend hours flipping on my iPad and I can see what
everybody thinks about something. And then I can also go deeper and I think,
well, this was a survey done and here's a specialist.
Surely he knows what he's talking about.
And I could base my life on popular opinion on what is politically correct.
What is everybody doing?
Or I could think I'm smart and I'm gonna go to the elite.
I'm gonna get somebody with a,
with some kind of a degree in front of their name. But here's what David says.
He says,
I could take all of that information and all of those people and I could
lift it up and it is lighter than a
breath. Why?
Because it's only manmade stuff. It, it does not help.
He goes on and he says in this passage that we can't put our trust in systems
and politics and all of this. It's here. He says, listen,
put no trust in exhortation, in vain hopes or robbery.
I've lived, I have lived under socialism. I've lived under totalitarianism.
I've lived under capitalism.
I've been somebody who's lived after a dictator in a country one time.
And you know what I found? None of them,
none of them is going to make a better world. It just won't work.
I cannot put my hope in that. He goes on and says,
put no hope in riches if, if your riches increase,
set not your heart on them. This verse is teaching me,
teaching you that we cannot trust a career path,
whether it's respectable or not. He says
to give us a sense of security and fulfillment.
So what can we trust in? What can we go to?
And the psalmist says, God,
God is the one that you can trust in God here in this passage is
both strong and he is loving.
This causes a lot of trouble for people.
The Bible says that God is a just and a holy God,
but he is a loving God. You'll hear it this way many times.
Well,
how does a loving God send an innocent person to Hell?
And I've read this book through many times,
and the Bible does not answer that question.
What the Bible answers is,
how does a holy and a just God allow a sinful
person like me to enter into his presence?
He loves me so much that he gave his only begotten son to
die for me on a cross. He,
he declares us guilty in our sin,
but then he takes our punishment on the cross.
Romans 6 23 says, the wages of sin is death,
but the gift of God is eternal life through Jesus Christ,
our Lord. Listen, if I believe that,
then when I'm going through the most difficult circumstances in my life,
I can also trust that same God
no matter how dark it gets, how desperate it gets.
I can trust God.
He has gone to every length to show us both his love and his
justice. And he is there for us.
We can pray. We can pray to the Lord and say, Lord, help me with,
with with help me to prosper in my work. But,
but don't let a career have power over me. Lord,
provide for my family's financial leads.
But don't ever let finances have a dominion over me. Lord,
you could pray.
I I I need not love the things that you have given me less as a blessing in
my life, but I need to love you more.
I need to love you as a giver and not the gift today.
That's our prayer today.
Here we also see a lesson of trusting God at all
times. I said it earlier, and I'm gonna say it again,
to be brought to a place where God is our only real hope is a
merciful experience. Desperation.
Desperation is one of the greatest in instructors
and how to trust God.
But it's also one of the greatest instructors or teachers in
the school of prayer.
Few things move us to pour out our hearts to God in earnest prayer.
Then when everything seems on the line
and we wonder if we're gonna make it,
these moments can happen in a second.
Everything can change. When I was writing this sermon
a week or so ago and reading this passage and studying it,
life was pretty good in our family.
Two and a half years ago, my sister had a grandson.
His name was Simon, who was a beautiful little boy.
But shortly after his birth, he developed cancer.
Our family went to our knees. We prayed,
we prayed. Lord, be merciful, heal little Simon. He's so precious.
He's such a gift. Lord, surely,
surely it's your will to keep him here with us and let his love on him to
raise him in your knowledge.
We prayed to God and God was merciful.
After six months of treatment, Simon went home.
He was out of the hospital
and been there and been just a normal fun little boy. Just the other day,
he had came to Oklahoma to visit his great-grandparents.
But last week Simon got to not feeling good.
And so they went to the doctor and they took a blood test. Blood test was,
was cur. It was, it was clean. But because of his,
his history with cancer, they took a blown, a bone marrow test.
And sure enough, the cancer, the cancer is returned. Simon,
today's in a hospital room doing two months of chemotherapy.
If that goes well and everything works,
he's looking at a bone trail, a bone transplant,
a bone marrow transplant. If a,
if a donor is found and he,
he could spend up to a year in a hospital room before he is able to leave.
None of us saw that coming.
But I was on a zoom call and on that zoom call,
there was three generations of our family praying for the fourth.
There is nothing like these kind of times.
It will teach us how to pray any better.
It drives us to our knees and we seek God.
Most people just do not run into a fortress unless
they're faced with real danger coming their way.
There's a story in the New Testament,
and it illustrates everything I've been talking about this morning. It's,
it's the, it's the story of Paul and Silas. You remember this story?
It's in Acts chapter 16. And, and, and the story is this.
They've been out preaching the gospel.
There's opposition to the preaching of the gospel.
And so they're arrested, they're tried. They're, they're innocent,
but they're declared guilty. The the, it's a Trump charge.
They're beaten and then they're placed in an inner prison.
And there they chains are put around their,
their ankles and they're shackled to the wall.
It's midnight. And listen, unlike me and most of us,
they're not doing what we would do. They are praying.
The Bible says, and they are singing to God.
And it says that all the prisoners were listening.
And then at midnight, an earthquake shook the foundation of this prison.
And all the doors were broken open and the chains fell off.
The prisoners were freed.
The jailer comes in and he says, SIRS,
what must I do to be saved? And they turn to him and say,
believe in the Lord Jesus Christ and you will be saved.
You know, I read that story and thought about that story,
and that has been my prayer for us as a church.
That every Sunday we come in here and in our desperation,
we would lift up our prayers. We would stand in silence before God,
and we would sing our praises to God and that people would
hear, and that there would be an earthquake in here,
and that change would be broken and doors would fly open and lies would be
changed. And Lord,
that the gospel would be heard and that people would surrender to Jesus as
their savior and Lord, amen. Amen.
I pray for that every Sunday.
Why not this Sunday? Why not today?
He's here. I'm here. You're here. The Spirit is here.
We live in victory because of what Christ has done
the other day. It's hot. And I don't have to remind you of that, right?
But the other day,
I just went outside in the darkness because it's cooler
and I just like being outside and I don't like hot.
And so I went outside and sat in the darkness.
You don't have to sit in the darkness outside, but, but let's just be honest.
If you want to see stars at night,
darkness is required, right? It's just the way it works.
The stars, they don't require darkness.
They don't even ask for darkness. In fact, the stars are shining all the time.
We could go outside right now and the stars are there.
They're doing what they do. We just can't see 'em.
We don't have to set in silence before the Lord during
these times in our life.
But
If you want to hear from God during these times,
silence is required.
Listen to Psalms 62 verse one.
For God, for God alone,
my soul waits
In silence.
We've learned. We've learned what David did.
David told us what we should do.
But let me ask you something.
What will you do?